j'ai décidé de faire un petit blind test
pour me tester et oui j'ai envie de
savoir si je suis dans des fraudes à
bout pas dans les gènes sont les
génériques de séries de télé ou de jeux
télé vous allez jouer avec moi chez vous
alors les chroniqueurs pouvais me
demandez ce que vous voulez je vous
chanterez des génériques et vous me
direz si j'ai bon ou pas ok attention
c'est parti qui veut démarrer b nai pas
si cher au courant de rien ce sont d
abord le foll est né à port louis
[Musique]
regardez écoutez
mika
j'suis danseurs mais je le sens pas
comme moi j'aimerais bien de new york
unité spéciale new york unité spéciale
mais qui connaît ça pour moi secretstory
secretstory alors benjamin da vinci code
story le dernier celui je donne cinq là
bas non ça c'est la star ac ça astarac
allende a assuré je connais pas c'est
l'émission je regardais jamais je
déteste et je laisserais l'animateur
[Rires]
sera différent car tu fais permis à
robert bédard
[Musique]
j'adore tout autre côte ouest
t'es pas là ce mélange de mensonges les
passions hu le long du grand pacifique
des vagues des filles
le temps presse était sa côte ouest
c'était bien moi c'était vraiment la
série moi j'étais plutôt voilà au
chômage de 2,2 de 10 ans à 30 ans donc
forcément je la regardais de société
qu'elle ait complété tous les midis
c'est une croix sur tf1 et en fait
c'était à 14 heures sur tf1 je le
regardais tous les jours parce que j'ai
fait moi j'ai fait vingt ans de pôle
emploi donc tu t'appelles autant je le
connaissais tout ça jean-michel vas-y
mon chéri je sais pas si c'est trop dur
ou pas magnum ouais c'est ça merci c'est
pour toi
[Musique]
oh ça c'est quand il monte les escaliers
parce que passe partout il met longtemps
vanté les qualités qui sont obligés
d'être une musique voilà à l'équipe
allait j'ai besoin d'un homme fort alors
oui mais gilles verdez dallas a web est
facile
c'est trop facile à la spa j je t'aime
mais franchement tu m'insultes tu
m'insultes rejoint j'admire ta la
nouvelle impitoyable merci y'a pas des
trucs un peu plus jeune ballet zine ben
ali révéler très bon c'est ta vie tu
sais tu habites je connais que le
pressing je connais pas les missions
merci ça cassait quelques personnes
alors l'agencé tous risques
aulas facile là c'est vraiment la
dernière chance au dernier moment
moi j'adorais je prenais pour poursuit t
elle est citée par apoula you fields et
ya du bal hannibal smith
ça va ça va ils ressemblaient pas du
tout rien à voir avec moi allez une
dernière une dernière bombe a sauté la
plus belle affiche déjà fait 100 fois
j'adore je suis fan fait schumi sur le
soleil sous le soleil en face ils jamais
facile seul et mary 2 et louis pareil
jusqu'à au nom veillé tout fermer les
yeux
c'est le même bleu j'adore parce qu'il a
fait
j'adore comprend pourquoi bien
pourquoi la vie bien plus belle ailleurs
on soit sevré tel meilleurs risques
ouais je suis toujours à d'autres qui
étaient au chômage 20 ans pour vous dire
qu'il ans